okay we're gonna talk about a real
attack on the press on on journalism on
free speech on the First Amendment but
but this is one that the press itself
has no interest in reporting on we're
gonna talk about that in a minute but
first let me tell you about light stream
are your credit card bills keeping you
up at night our interest rates in the
double digits this is the kind of thing
that weighs on you it's the kind of
thing that makes it hard to enjoy life
when you have this weight on your
shoulders and you're worried about debt
and everything but luckily there is a
way out a way to lighten the load be
smart and pay off your credit card
balances with a credit card
consolidation loan from light stream get
a fixed rate as low as five point nine
five percent APR with Auto pay you could
save thousands in interest and and get
this you you can get a loan from five to
ten thousand dollars and there are no
fees to worry about plus just to make it
better to give you more peace of mind
because that's what this is really all
about light stream is a division of
SunTrust Bank one of the nation's
largest financial institutions so you
know you've got nothing to worry about
want to save even more well I'm sure you
do we all do my listeners get an
additional interest rate discount the
only way okay so you got to pay
attention the only way to get this
discount is to go to light stream comm
slash Walsh Li gh t stre a m.com slash
Walsh subject to credit approval rate
includes 0.5% auto pay discount terms
and conditions apply okay so we hear
that the press is under attack that
journalists are courageous martyrs that
the government is stomping on the First
Amendment to hinder the work of these
brave you know warriors for truth the
only problem is that most of the time
when you hear this stuff the people who
make this claim have difficulty citing
any examples they'll say this but then
what examples do they give you well
they'll say well you know Trump says
mean stuff about CNN or they'll talk
about some of the mean gifts and it is
gift not jiff
that Trump retweets about the media but
as for actual legal persecution of the
press
they don't seem to have very many
examples of that that they can provide
right or at least I should say there
aren't very many examples that they
would want to provide in the left-wing
media but here's one this is one of the
ones they don't like but we've got one
this is a real live example here okay we
caught one here this really is an attack
on the press this is a tackle on the
First Amendment it is chilling
terrifying potentially disastrous for
the First Amendment itself it is an
assault on the work of journalists so
here it is right right here guys if
you're looking for an example you found
it it's right here
except even though it's the best example
of government persecution of journalists
in America it's also the one example the
journalists in America will ignore or
even defend David daleiden and Sandra
Merritt are two journalists with the
Center for medical progress maybe you
recognize their names you should if you
don't there are the people who
infiltrated Planned Parenthood in an
undercover investigation a few years ago
and they revealed widespread criminal
conduct at every level of the
organization they revealed among other
things that Planned Parenthood haggles
over and sells the body parts of of the
babies that they kill and we'll get to
this in a second but I know that if any
liberal that's watching this will say
well it's deceptively edited
no it wasn't we'll get to that in a
second but that's what it proved rather
than it leading to the prosecution of
the crooks at Planned Parenthood who are
engaged in this McCobb form of human
trafficking it has led to the
prosecution of the journalists who
discovered the crime and which is a
basically if you look up shooting the
messenger in the dictionary you're gonna
find this case that's what's happening
here the state of California first when
Kamala Harris was Attorney General and
now with Xavier Becerra both absurdly
and openly biased in favor of Planned
Parenthood and against these journalists
both recipients of donations from
Planned Parenthood both who have pledged
to stand with Planned Parenthood
nonetheless the state of California led
by the the tube part of these two
partisan minions of the abortion
industry has been trying to punish
daleiden and Merritt for years now for
exposing these crimes for engaging in
journalism the kind of journalism that
other journalists aren't going to do
trying to exact vengeance on them
essentially for embarrassing Planned
Parenthood now they claim a state of
California claims that their Planned
Parenthood's privacy has been invaded
and that that's the great crime here but
of course privacy is always invaded in
undercover journalism that's part of the
point right if there's some truth that's
being hidden from the public some truth
that the public has a right to know
about and that's what undercover
journalism is supposed to do is to tell
the public things that we should know
but we're not being told because it's
being kept from us such as by the way
Planned Parenthood which gets 500
million dollars a year in in welfare
payments from the government is selling
body parts that's something we should
know our money is going to this
organization we have a right to know it
but if it's being kept from you if lies
are being told if secrets are being kept
then the only way to reveal it is to
invade the privacy of this organization
which is what they did which is what
undercover journalists again always do
and if this is a criminal case of
invasion of privacy then nobody can ever
do undercover journalism again that's
what's at stake here not the media cares
there was a I believe it was in
California where there was a few years
ago an undercover investigation done at
I think it was like meatpacking plants
and you hear about this kind of stuff
all the time where someone infiltrates
one of these organizations to try to
find out what's happening so that they
can tell the public
that's undercover journalism if
daleiden and Sandra Merritt can't do
that then nobody can do it so these two
journalists have been charged with 15
felony counts the case was was stayed by
the California Supreme Court a few weeks
ago but now it's moving forward and now
California will will have the ability to
try to lock these people in prison for
for doing this so just to review okay a
partisan Attorney General who was
support a supporter of Planned
Parenthood and a recipient of Planned
Parenthood money is leading the
prosecution against two undercover
journalists who expose illegal activity
within Planned Parenthood the
organization that gives him money attack
on the press on journalism on speech
yeah I would say that's what it is now a
few points it will be said as I
referenced earlier that it has been said
a million times that the undercover
Planned Parenthood videos were
deceptively edited this has been the
slogan of abortion apologists for years
now ever since these videos came out
they say it reflexively reflexively
almost like a hiccup
they can't even help themselves the
moment you bring it up they're
deceptively edited deceptively edited
and if it were true that daleiden and
merit basically went in there and you
know using camera tricks or something
they made up a bunch of stuff and lied
about what they discovered and made it
seem like Planned Parenthood was selling
baby parts when really they weren't
which when someone calls it deceptively
edited that's what they're implying that
no they didn't really discover that they
just made it seem like that which
already that there should be red flags
there because you know I feel like you
could do an undercover investigation of
me and record everything that I say
secretly and then deceptively edit it
and in doing that you may be able to
accuse me and make it seem like I said a
lot of things I didn't say I don't think
even with with with the most deceptive
of editing you could make it seem like I
ever tried to sell a baby's kidney right
because I just
unless you're hiring voice actors to
come in and dub over what I actually
said I there's no way just anything that
I say there's no way you could slice it
up in any form
that'll make it sound like I'm trying to
sell a dead body that'd be very dead
that's a that's a difficult form of
deceptive editing so that should have
been red-flagged when you hear this
claim of deceptive editing but the point
is if it was deceptively edited then
then yeah in that case this would not be
an undercover investigation this would
just be a smear campaign and yeah sure
go ahead and prosecute just like Chris
Hanson used to do those undercover
stings to catch child molesters I think
he might still do them actually and yeah
and he invaded their privacy he lied he
met them under false pretenses he did
all that but it was considered okay
because it was an undercover
investigation to expose child predators
and it's sort of understood that unless
you are secretive about it and and and
sneaky you're not gonna be able to know
child molesters gonna show up if he
knows that he's gonna be on TV in the
middle of an investigation
but if Hanson had edited the tape to
make someone look like a child molester
who really was there to deliver a pizza
or something then he would have gotten
in trouble for that obviously so were
the Planned Parenthood videos
deceptively edited no no they were not
it has been proven that they weren't I
want to emphasize that it has been
proven that they were not deceptively
edited the people who say that they were
deceptively edited are either ignorant
or lying there is no third option now
they weren't deceptively edited were
they edited at all well obviously they
were it was hours and hours of video
footage and a lot of irrelevant material
has to be cut out so that it's
digestible and so that it's something
that people will watch if they just
release 13 hours of tape and say hey
sort through it and find what you find
then it's going to have no impact
because no one's going to watch it
you're just you're not going to do that
you're gonna release the highlight the
point
as long as you put it in context and you
properly represent it then it is not a
deceptive edit the Fifth Circuit Court
of Appeals ruled recently of course you
didn't hear this in the news they ruled
that the videos were not deceptively
edited here's what the court said
reading now the record reflects that Oh
IG Office of Inspector General had
submitted a report from a forensic firm
concluding that the video was authentic
and not deceptively edited and the
plaintiffs Planned Parenthood did not
identify any particular omission or
addition in the video footage there is
no question that the OIG here made
factual findings after viewing the
videos and related evidence on the basis
of the administrative record and so it
goes on from there so they did a
forensic analysis and they did not find
any deceptive editing but it gets better
okay Planned Parenthood itself hired its
own investigators hired fusion GPS
actually you may right you may remember
them hired them to do an analysis and
prove that the that there were deceptive
edits again this is an analysis that was
that was paid for subsidized by Planned
Parenthood and now I'll read let me let
me read from their report once again
this is from Planned Parenthood or at
least the people they hired they're
gonna try to dress this up as favorably
for themselves as they can here's what
they said Fusion GPS analysts reviewed
all four of the full footage videos
released by the Center for medical
progress totaling more than twelve hours
of tape this analysis did not reveal
widespread evidence of substantive video
manipulation but we did identify cuts
skips missing tape and changes in camera
angle a forensic video expert grant
Frederick's reviewed segments of tape
identified as suspicious during this
preliminary review this professional
analysis revealed that the full footage
videos contain numerous intentional
post-production edits while many of
these edits removed likely irrelevant
content from the beginning and end of
the interviews all four videos also
contained intentional edits that removed
content from the middle of the videos
okay did you get that
this analysis did not reveal widespread
evidence of substantive video
manipulation this is from like three
years ago
that Planned Parenthood admitted that
there wasn't deceptive edits and you
still hear this from the media that
there were deceptive edits the best they
could do is say well there weren't
deceptive edits but there were
intentional edits well of course there
were intentional edits yes there are
cuts and skips because obviously you're
you're going to make cuts to any video
that you film and then release to mass
consumption almost every piece of
footage you have ever watched on the
news on any channel at any point
anywhere has been has has cuts and skips
and missing pieces of it because that's
the way it works the question is whether
those cuts and skips are meant to
deceive meant to give a false impression
meant to make it seem like something is
happening when it's not really happening
the answer that we get now from two
forensic investigations into the footage
one funded by Planned Parenthood is that
no the edits were not deceptive they're
just irrelevant cutting out your
relevant stuff so that's it that's the
end you you you cannot claim anymore
that these videos were deceptively
edited unless you are willing to be a
blatant despicable liar and I know that
a lot of Pro borscht people are willing
to be that but I mean really look in the
mirror and ask yourself are you happy
being that because I wouldn't be no
matter how you feel the subject you just
have to deal with it that this stuff is
on tape this is it's when you watch the
tape and you hear someone from Planned
Parenthood trying to sell a body parts
that's what happened you might not like
it you might wish it didn't happen I
wish it didn't happen - but it did
period okay so if the video was not
deceptively edited then what does that
mean it means that when Planned
Parenthood officials are caught on tape
haggling over the price of a dead baby's
liver it's real it happens
and it's illegal and these journalists
exposed actual illegal activity and now
they're being prosecuted for it because
that's that really is what this all
comes down to if if the if if the videos
are real then this is a legitimate
investigation and they uncovered at a
minimum they uncovered widespread
unethical activity at a minimum when
really it is federal crimes they
uncovered that's investigative
journalism even if you don't like the
results and so this is again if they if
they are successfully prosecuted for
this and they go to jail or they face
you know some kind of legal penalty the
the implications for all of journalism
are vast and troubling alright let's
move on I've got to light in the light
in the mood a little bit I've got two
extremely awkward videos to play one
courtesy of Democrats and one courtesy
of Republicans we're going to be
bipartisan and so here's the first from
Kamala Harris we have a little fun
kicker that we like to do with all of
the presidential candidates that come on
it's called candidate mixtape that was
the musical sting for it and we'd like
to talk a lot about music here on this
program so what is your favorite musical
genre oh I mean um hip hop and reggae
and jazz those are those are some of my
face okay do you have a favorite band or
a favorite musician I'd say one of my
favorites is Bob Marley good choice you
can't go wrong with that that's a crowd
pleaser
on your mixtape what would be like your
favorite three songs oh okay let's see
I read the Franklin anything of read the
Franklin I would say Bob Marley and then
I don't know I love cardi B as she says
those are great thank you for playing
along oh man lord help us lord save us
yeah that I I can't I could barely get
through that the first time I it took me
like five tries to watch that whole
minute long clip because it is the
second hand embarrassment is so extreme
that I could like as I can't stomach it
and I'm gonna leave aside the fact that
a presidential candidate lends her
endorsement to cardi B a woman who
admits to drugging and robbing men so
let's we'll put that to the side even
though really we shouldn't but I will
it's obvious that Camille Harris has
never listened to music in her life and
you know she lists Aretha Franklin and
Bob Marley as two of her favorite songs
on her mixtape and I'm not sure if she
knows what mixtape is I'm not even sure
if she knows what song is my favorite
song is uh Elvis Presley by the Beatles
from the album Radiohead hi kids
I'm cool too it's you know let me just
say if if you don't like music just say
that you don't listen to music it's okay
because I not the first person to fall
victim to this when you've been in a
conversation you're talking about your
favorite bands or whatever and someone
turns to someone I'll hit what do you
listen to and you could tell they're
trying to come up with because you can
tell they don't listen to anything which
is fine you don't have to listen to
music it's not it's not a requirement I
think it's a little weird to not listen
to music it's a guy for me it seems like
a really human it's like a human need
almost music is but if you don't listen
you know this is fine it's okay you know
you're not a bad person you could just
say oh you know I don't really listen to
anything it's just doesn't interest me
but then you've got but people don't
want to say that because they feel like
they're gonna be judged which they will
be a little bit if you don't listen to
music I'm gonna judge you a small amount
not that just a little bit of judgement
I'm gonna throw at you and it will fade
don't worry just um it's just a little
little moment of judgment no big deal
but that's better than the alternative
where you start making up your favorite
genre off the top of your head and now
the judgment is heavy now it is just
these are just it's like a machine gun
of judgment coming at you whereas before
it was just a little squirt gun so that
was pretty bad all right now let's be
bipartisan ben Carson is the head of
Housing and Urban Development for some
reason the word housing is right there
in the name so you'd think he'd be
familiar with super basic real estate
terms that even hi know and and I don't
know anything about real estate but you
know he was he was he was at a hearing
for the House Financial Services
Committee and here's how that went as
you look it up I'd also like you to get
back to me if you don't mind to explain
the disparity in REO rates do you know
what an REO is and Oriya are not an Oreo
an REO are real estate what's the O
stand for the organization owned real
estate owned that's what
when a property goes to foreclosure we
call it an REO and FHA loans have much
higher REO s that is they go to
foreclosure rather than to loss
mitigation or to non foreclosure
alternatives like short sales than
comparable loans at the GSEs so I'd like
to know why we're having more
foreclosures that end in people losing
their homes with stains to their credit
and disruption to their communities and
their neighborhoods at FHA then we are
at the GSEs now that one see that's not
even funny so much is just baffling one
of the weirdest decisions that Trump
ever made was taking Ben Carson a
world-renowned surgeon and rather than
making him Surgeon General or head of
Health and Human Services making him the
head of housing out of all of all of the
jobs to give him he obviously has no
basis of knowledge at all even now after
two years he doesn't know basic real
estate terms and but you know that's
okay because he's literally a surgeon
there's a whole job and government set
aside for somebody like that why not
give him that job if you feel like you
got to give him a job in the government
in the first place I actually thinks
yeah I take this kind of personally
because all right this whole ben Carson
thing to me is very sad I mean this guy
is a medical genius one of the great
surgeons in history and that gets lost
in this when people talk about Ben
Carson's become this joke but he's he's
not he's oh he's a genius what this guy
was able to do in the medical field it
was a he's a pioneer in the medical
field he was he was performing you know
he was separating conjoined twins
conjoined at the head before anyone was
doing it he was doing it just medical
marvels this man was pulling off for
decades this is also a guy who who came
from the came from nothing it came from
destitute poverty and became inclined
his way up and and became one of the
most respected world-renowned high
nearing surgeons in the world in history
but then he decides to get into politics
and now he'll be remembered as this kind
of bumbling political figure even though
he's a man of incredible brilliance and
accomplishment
yet he decided to become a bureaucrat so
you see this this is the lesson here
it's you become a bureaucrat and this is
what happens if if if bureaucracy can
make even someone like Ben Carson look
like that who is a genius again for the
third time and hat certainly has a much
higher IQ than any of the people making
fun of him but if it can do that and
make him look like that then what do you
think it could do to the rest of us I
just that's why when when you know Ben
Carson he he he you know he retired from
his from the medical field fine
well-deserved retirement and then he's
you know he appears he does a few
speaking engagements he appears here and
there and he he says a few things
critical of Obama I guess and he makes a
few political statements that
conservatives agree with and that's fine
but then everyone sees is on to this guy
and next thing you know he's running for
president and it's like no we don't just
just because he said a few things we
agree with we don't need to make him a
presidential candidate he's not a
there's not necessarily a lot of
crossover between what it takes to be a
great president than what it takes to be
a great surgeon both take a lot of skill
but they're not the same skills at all
so there's no reason for that why
couldn't ben Carson have just remained a
retired surgeon who comes out and speaks
and engages in the national conversation
but he's not a political figure he's not
a bureaucrat he's not running for office
nothing like that
it's just his home man why couldn't have
just been that it's a damn shame
all right let's discuss something
something else non-political before we
go
well that was political so we'll discuss
something non-political for once before
we
into emails let's talk about jewelry
girls will have a little girl talk
because there's nobody better to lead
that conversation than me I know when
you're thinking about let's have a girl
talk let's talk to your with the first
person you think you want me to be the
one to lead that discussion a few days
ago somebody on Twitter I'm not gonna
throw her name and Twitter handle out
there because I'm not trying to add to
the dog pile but I do want to talk about
this subject so I'm just using this as
the entrance into the subject she so
this woman on Twitter said I would dump
a guy if he got me a nasty cheap Pandora
ring for my engagement a guy spends
twenty percent of his yearly salary on a
ring
don't you agree girls now then I'm not
even this might even be a parody account
honestly I'm not sure it's hot it's
impossible to tell anymore what's a
parody what isn't I don't know it
doesn't really matter the point is I
want to talk about this whole thing this
tradition of buying a very expensive
piece of jewelry because dirt during but
before you know before you get married
during this discussion on social media
some people and these were real people
for sure basically came to this woman's
defense and told me that the rule is
this is the rule the tradition the
custom is that you're supposed to spend
two months salary so four to eight pay
periods worth on an engagement ring that
is the tradition two months salary now
look look let's be clear that the
tradition of spending two months salary
on a ring is like the tradition of going
to a designer clothes store and spending
$86 on a t-shirt it may be something
that people do out of vanity it may be
something that a lot of people do it may
be something people have been doing for
a little while now but it's not some
sort of deep ancient human custom that
we have to preserve at all cost
most humans on earth throughout the
history of the earth have not spent that
kind of money on t-shirts and they don't
spend that kind of money on jewelry so
it's it's it is this is not really a
human tradition that dates back very far
these are customs invented by the
companies who sell the stuff okay
the keepers the preservers of the two
months salary for a ring
custom our jewelry stores not
surprisingly because they profit from it
the custom was the custom was invented
somewhat recently by jewelry stores and
it is totally crazy it is just
completely crazy you you're starting out
your life together you're beginning the
journey probably you don't have a lot of
money most young married couples don't
some do and you know what if you're a
Millie if you're a multi-millionaire
then everything I'm saying put to the
side I mean do what you want it's a
you've got the money I guess but talking
to normal people in a normal situation
you're getting married you don't have a
lot of money or start your journey
together this is the way it was for me
and my wife we got married seven years
ago and you're gonna start out in a
financial hole so that you can spend
four to eight paychecks on a fashion
accessory if you were think about the
saving that that requires and you're
gonna take all of that saving then
you've been doing leading up to your
wedding and you're gonna dump it all
into a little rock that someone's gonna
wear on their finger until it gets
knocked into the you know into it into
the trash can accidentally and thrown
away so I just I don't get it I I think
it's I think it's completely crazy if I
if I went out and bought my wife a ring
and I gave it to her and it was
beautiful and she loved it and then and
then she asked what she would eventually
and then she asked well how does a good
how much was this and I said oh you know
just two months salary diet don't worry
just two months salary I mean the you
know the kids kids don't need to eat for
a couple weeks it's it's it's fine she
would have me committed to an
institution if I did that she would she
wouldn't even be angry about it she
would be terrified she would be scared
she would assume that I'd gone crazy to
do something like that and and and I
would have to be crazy to ever do
something like that we've got this idea
that in order to enter into some new
important phase of life you have to
spend tons and tons of money first and
this is completely
artificial this is one of the reasons
why so many young people are putting off
adulthood and putting off the entering
into these new and exciting phases
because they think that you need to have
tons of money to do it
when you don't it is completely
artificial you can get married for free
if you want getting married doesn't have
to cost you anything you could do it for
free or you could spend a few hundred
bucks and have a cookout and and you
know you could buy it in its inexpensive
ring on clearance you can have a cookout
with with your family and friends and
you can spend a few hundred bucks and be
done with it
you could get through the whole thing
and you can get through the whole thing
for less than a grand easily or you
could spend thousands and thousands and
thousands of dollars putting yourself
into debt your parents into debt
probably also that you can what show off
to everybody so you can have the
pageantry and the really nice thing and
the really nice table arrangements and
everything is really nice everyone will
talk about how nice it is and they'll
put it on Facebook and then you can put
your picture of your ring on Facebook
and all of that or you could do
something in between which is what me
and my wife did you know our our whole
wedding experience definitely didn't
cost only a thousand bucks I'll say that
it was probably too expensive wasn't
nearly as expensive as what some people
do but it was probably too expensive and
and that's because there's there's a lot
of pressure and force as a young person
as a young couple kind of pulling you in
the direction of spending a ton of money
on everything and you're kind of tricked
into thinking well this is really
important to you then you're gonna spend
this money oh this woman you want to
marry her she's not worth it
she's not worth spending $12,000 on a
ring isn't she worth it to you or it's
it suspense it's most it's a most
special day of your life it's a special
day so of course you got to spend forty
thousand dollars on a wedding it's a
special day well yes it is a very
special day it is it is gonna be one of
the most special days of your life
alongside when you're when your kids are
born but since when does that mean you
have to spend tens of thousands of
dollars so
when the special mean have to mean
expensive it doesn't you know it's the
same kind of thing with college college
has a you know has to be a hundred
thousand dollars weddings have to cost
tens of thousands dollars I mean just to
get married and get educated we're
saying that young people have to you
need need to either be children of oil
tycoons or they need to go into debt and
I think that's crazy
here's it here's the point a ring is not
going to keep your marriage together at
all
a fancy wedding is not going to keep it
together no marriage in history has ever
been permanently sustained by the
financial commitment that went into it
except maybe Bill and Hillary so maybe
there are a few exceptions but for most
of us for the vast majority of marriages
the thing that's going to sustain it is
no matter how much your wedding cost no
matter how much your ring costs what
sustains the marriage is love devotion
sacrifice duty service faith that's
what's going to do it and if you don't
have those things but you've got the
nicest ring and you have the fanciest
reception it you know your marriage
won't last six months and then on not
only do you have a devastating divorce
but you've also wasted all this money
that you can't get back so don't do it
kids keep keep it getting married for
cheap that's my recommendation
everything involved in the marriage do
it for cheap save the money spend it on
something more important build a nest
egg you won't regret it
I I don't think anyone has ever after
getting married look back and said I
wish we spent more money on that wedding
you know that's my one regret my one
regret in life is that we had it we got
married for $2,000 for ours I wish we
had spent forty five thousand no one
ever says that and I also don't think
that there are a lot of women out there
correct me if I'm wrong ladies but you
get married you love your husband he's a
devoted devoted husband becomes a
devoted father if your wedding ring
wasn't that expensive or your engagement
ring are you waking up every day just
that the ring isn't expensive enough if
so you're a shallow miserable person so
I'm going to assume that that's not the
case and anyway down the line once
you've been married and you save some
money as a man you know if you want to
treat your wife then and go out and buy
her more expensive ring now that you've
got the money and you can do it you can
afford it you can always do that you can
buy your wife jewelry anytime you don't
need to do it when you're both broke and
not even married yet
all right um let's see Matt Walsh show
at gmail.com Matt well show at gmail.com
this is from Erin says hi Matt thanks
for doing the show it's great on the
show you stated that you don't believe
that upping the age to buy tobacco
products and vaping should would be
beneficial do you feel the same about
firearms I feel there should be one age
to do everything say 19 buy and carry
guns buy alcohol tabacco joined the
military drive a car all other things
that dolts are entitled to do 19 would
keep all this out of high schools
thoughts is kind of interesting you
think of someone doing all of that all
at once in one day I mean that would
make for a really interesting 19th
birthday got my god I got my cigar I got
my got my booze let's go join the
military folks oh yeah and I'm driving -
no I I actually think that's uh I think
it's good to taper some of this stuff so
that you're not doing it all at once I
think that if anything it makes sense to
have the drinking age lower than the
driving age so that maybe you know you
can introduce a teenager to drinking
responsibly before they can even drive
so you know if the worry as much about
drunk driving although they could still
do it obviously but less of a chance so
doesn't that make sense doesn't it
doesn't it make sense to drive because
again we go back to you're you're
telling me that it's 16 somebody is
competent enough to drive a huge tin box
70 miles per hour down the highway
they're competent enough for that but
you wouldn't trust them with the Sam
Adams my thinking is if
this is someone you really can't trust
with the Sam Adams then I'm not gonna
trust them with an SUV so I think maybe
we you know the Sam Adams the beer
should be one of the first things when
it comes to the adult things that we are
allowing teenagers to start doing and
introducing them to I think probably the
beer should be one of the first things
like why you get that down if you're in
less you don't want want to drink what's
great but if you do let's get that down
let's figure out how to do that
responsibly and and then maybe we can
move on to some of these other things so
I that's how I would look at all right
um this is from hold on this from
William says hey Matt I've just recently
started watching your podcast I love
them I've been watching them going
backwards now and one of them you answer
a question
these could podcast will be very
confusing if you watch them backwards so
I would recommend I would recommend the
traditional forwards method
I'll be watching them going backwards
now and one of them you answer question
saying we should explore outer space
I was curious which one you think is
more important to explore space or deep
into the ocean because we consistently
keep finding strange creatures from the
ocean thank you for taking the time to
read this and I love your show
yeah it is a fascinating thing that
there is so much still on earth that we
have not explored there's so much about
our oceans that we do not know the
oceans are very mysterious to us because
we haven't seen most of it especially
under the surface and you know what I
wouldn't even rank them William I'm all
about I think we should explore
everything I think it's great explore
the oceans explore the space explore the
uncharted wilderness which still exists
jungles oceans Antarctica explore
everything let's let's why not let's
find out about this world we live in
we're not here for very long I mean this
is our chance to explore it so let's do
that all right from Rose says hi Matt
love the shelve impressed by the fact
that you have hobbies you talk about
beekeeping and fishing it seems like you
also do a great deal of reading how do
you find time for these hobbies and how
do you develop them I hate being the
kind of person with no real interests
aside from watching TV but that's what's
happened to me did you just decide to
become a beekeeper one day and do it how
did it work yeah I
good question I do have I guess what I
would call maybe three hobbies so
fishing beekeeping now it's and that's
new and and I've always liked to read I
actually did kind of just decide one day
that I wanted to have hobbies like I did
I was like you I didn't have any hobbies
and and and I said I would I just I feel
like I'd like to have hobbies I think I
don't want to be the kind of person who
doesn't have hobbies and so what I
started by doing is I literally looked
up I googled a list of hobbies on just
google the hobby suggestions or
something and I started scrolling
through it saying if anything piqued my
interest and I saw a few things and I
tried a few things out brewing beer was
when I tried gardening I thought you
know I I liked garden fresh tomatoes
maybe I'll do some gardening tried
brewing beer tried a few different
things one hobby I saw suggested was a
knife making and I still might pick that
one up I put that one on to the side
that requires a lot of equipment but I
like the idea of that that's cool tried
something else didn't really click and
ultimately I decided to go with
beekeeping because I this is something
about it's always been in the back of my
mind I've always been interested in it
and I said I'll just do it why not and
fishing developed a little bit over time
because we've vacationed at lakes a lot
I think although now it's become kind of
an obsession for me so it kind of picked
up gradually and now I am somewhat
obsessed with fishing I think it's it is
important to have hobbies and that's why
I decided I wanted to develop some the
advantage of having hobbies is that for
one I think it makes you a more
interesting person not not saying you're
not interesting but I think I'm just get
there there are more things about you
right if someone asks you ask you to
describe yourself talk about yourself
you have more things you can say about
yourself because that becomes kind of
troubling doesn't it when you you know
have you ever been stumped by that
question when someone a really basic web
so someone said you know tell me about
yourself and you realize that you have
almost nothing to say you don't even
know what you can say about yourself so
I think part of picking up hobbies is
just having some things about your
self so that's good and it also it gives
you specific specialized knowledge about
something which is important it makes I
think it's good to be that's part of my
thinking process with a hobby is I I
want to have some subjects that I just
know really well even if I can't use
that information quote-unquote on a
day-to-day basis I think it's good to
just know things and to have certain
areas that you know really well and that
you're an expert on now I'm not an
expert on any of these things yet but
I'm learning about it and I know a lot
more about it now that I did before and
I probably know more than the average
person because this is what I've been
learning about and then what you find is
you start building this base of
knowledge that seems irrelevant although
it's not irrelevant because no knowledge
is irrelevant because it's enriching for
you it's enriching for your mind so it
can't be irrelevant but you start
building this base of knowledge that
seems at least not functional and then
what you find is that you you kind of
branch off from there and you start
learning other things related to it and
then the knowledge grows so part of
fishing is it starts by learning about
the kind of fish that you're you know
specifically what kind of things do they
eat what kind of lures do you use so on
and so forth now you start learning
about lakes and different bodies of
water and you know different habitats
for different kinds of wildlife you
start branching off and learning even
more so that's another advantage and i
don't--there's just gives you access to
new social communities that people who
like the same kind of stuff teaches you
patience I'm a big advocate for it so I
would say as far as how to get into a
new hobby which I guess was your
question which I haven't answered I
think you just pick one and start doing
it find something that seems vaguely
interesting to you pick it up start
doing it here's how you'll know that um
that that this is a hobby that might
click for you is when you when you first
start doing it you're depending on what
it is you're probably not going to be
good at it you'll probably be very bad
at it and clueless but if you can still
enjoy it
you've even kind of mysteriously enjoy
it like you don't even even know why you
enjoy doing this thing but you do and
you enjoy learning about it and reading
about it then I think that's a hobby
that will stick if you try it for months
and you're bad at it and you don't enjoy
it and it just is terrible the other you
think just give it up and find a new one
that one's not for you but if you can
enjoy it when you're bad at it
then that means it's a good hobby and it
also means eventually you'll probably be
really good at it
so that's my thoughts on hobby obviously
all right uh we will i think leave it
there thanks everybody for watching
thanks for listening
Godspeed a new survey of IQ scores
throughout the West shows us that our
intelligence is plummeting you only have
to look around at the 2020 Democrat
presidential candidates or the force of
congressional testimony on the hill to
see that this is very likely true we
asked the question are we all just
getting stupider check it out at the
Michael Knowles show